all right great thanks for coming so
I'll be talking about simple efficient
than neural algorithms for sparse coding
so the last time I used this joke was in
or agui and I only see one person who
was there with me so I'm a theoretical
computer scientist then an applied math
department will be telling you about
neuroscience so trust me this will be
joint work with Sanjeev Arora Rangga and
tengu maan
so actually I want to start off this
talk okay I want to start off this talk
with a citation first so about 20 years
ago there was this landmark paper
written by all chosen and field called
the emergence of simple cell receptive
field properties by learning a sparse
code for natural images so this paper
introduced sparse coding and it
connected it to neuroscience and what it
offered was the idea that actually a
scientific mystery namely how did
neurons in the visual cortex get the
types of receptive field properties that
they're observed to have that that
question could be explained by
connecting it to an optimization problem
that they believed that neurons were
trying to solve so let me tell you about
this experiment it's a very interesting
experiment that you can try in the break
so what you do is you take large
collections of natural images and you
break them up into patches so either 8
by 8 or 16 by 16 blocks now each of
those patches is then a vector in some
low dimensional space and you think
about this a very large collection of
vectors and so what they did was they
asked for a basis that enabled a sparse
representation of those images so that's
sparse coding more precisely sparse
coding is an optimization problem which
they gave nearly plausible heuristics
for doing and what they found was that
when they applied those heuristics to
natural images they recovered a basis
which resembled many of the properties
of the Gabor filters so it actually had
a lot of the properties that
neuroscientists were looking for in the
visual you know knew were in the visual
cortex for example these bases were
localized bandpass and oriented now to
contrast this you know another technique
that you can do is you could take this
collection of vectors and
could apply the singular value
decomposition in which case what you're
looking for are directions that explain
as much of the variance and the vectors
as possible but the trouble is that if
you apply the SVD to vectors that you
get from natural images what you get is
very noisy difficult to interpret in
extremely dense so what I'll be
interested in this talk is are they're
efficient and also neroli plausible
algorithms for sparse coding ones that
take advantage of just the very simple
operations like matrix vector
multiplication and Thresh holding yet
what we're gonna show is that even
algorithms constructed from such simple
operations can solve highly non-trivial
optimization problems so the first part
in this talk I'm going to tell you about
all xiao xin of fields update rule the
usual formulation for sparse coding is a
highly non convex optimization problem
and all Shannon Fields heuristic comes
along with a neural implementation a
plausible guess about how a neural
architecture might do it and I'll
introduce you to the natural generative
model for thinking about these problems
to move beyond the usual worst-case
analysis and I'll tell you about prior
work and the second part what I'm going
to do is I'm going to give you a new
update rule inspired by all chosen and
field very similar and in some sense is
actually simpler which it'll have these
nice properties that its online local
and heavy and as we'll see and yet it
will actually have provable guarantees
in these generative models and the main
idea will be to connect this heuristic
and analyze it by connecting it to
approximate gradient descent so that's
the main outline for the talk and the
usual non convex formulation for sparse
coding is what you're doing is you're
looking for a basis these are the
columns of a in such a way that all of
your examples these be eyes have a
sparse representation or at least the
somewhat closeby sparse representation
so this here is called the
reconstruction errors that you look for
each example you look at how much of BI
you haven't explained with a times X I X
I is the representation but the other
thing is that you want that these X of
eyes should be sparse that you've
explained your your examples as sparse
linear combinations of the columns of a
so what you do is you add in some
linear penalty function which serves the
goal of trying to encourage sparsity
because it's something which is very
large on dense vectors and a small on
sparser ones so it won't be so important
what that is precisely for us we'll work
with hard thresholds anyways but the
trouble with analyzing heuristics for
solving this problem is that this
problem really is np-hard and a cannon
does have many local optimum but
heuristics seem to work well
nevertheless empirically so also hasn't
in field what they did was they did more
than just give a heuristic they gave an
architecture that implements it it's a
very simple architecture in which there
are three layers there's the image which
it's the stimulus layer where the image
is presented you have the residual error
which tracks your residual error so far
how much of the image haven't you
explained you have a top layer which
outputs a sparse representation you're
given basis and this is where the
learning happens you know where is the
basis that enables a sparse
representation
well it's stored as synapse weights that
connect this layer to this leg so the
idea is well when you're presented with
an image you've explained none of its so
far so you add it entirely into the
residual and then you multiply by a
transpose and you use that to compute
your sparse representation and you also
feed back steps where you then update
what your residual is so the important
point is that the way you should think
about this is what it's trying to do is
it's trying to perform gradient descent
by alternating between two different
steps one where you take your current
representation in your current basis and
you calculate what your residual vector
is and the other one where you actually
update what your sparse representation
is so it does these updates and the
important point is that this is a method
for outputting a sparse code once the
dictionary is fixed but there's also a
heavy n rule which specifies how a is
updated over time as you see more and
more examples what really happens is the
weights tying the two different layers
get updated in some manner so the real
question is do simple and local and
hebbian rules find globally optimal
solutions these things like this can
they be analyzed rigorously and there's
some hope here in that
there's been a lot of recent success in
analyzing things like altering
minimization for ranging from problems
from matrix completion of phase
retrieval robust pca and so on so we'll
be drawing on some of that work and the
model that we're gonna work with you
know after all this problem is hard in
the worst case we're gonna be working
with the following generative model
which is gonna make our problem well
posed and not adversarial so there's
some unknown dictionary which is the
basis that enables a sparse
representation and then every example be
that you're given really is a sparse
linear combination of the columns of a
so one way you might think about doing
this is choosing for example X to be
random so that it is case bars you can
choose its support randomly or somewhat
randomly and then you can choose the
nonzero values independently once you've
conditioned on the support now there are
a lot of extensions thus gener to model
where the algorithms will still work but
with slightly relaxed guarantees but I
don't want to get into too much of the
details about all the different variants
the generative model but this is the
simplest one to think about now there's
been a lot of work in theoretical
computer science lately on designing
algorithms for dictionary learning
finding a basis given a random sample
from this model so the work of Spielman
Wang and right what they did was they
worked for dictionaries which have full
column rank so the constraint is that if
it's an N by n matrix M has to be at
most n so that's called the so called
under complete case and they worked with
sparsely about root N and joint work
with sons even long we gave algorithms
for what are called over complete
dictionaries so they can have many more
columns than rows that allows your basis
the more flexibly adapt to the data
you're given and they work with what are
called incoherent dictionaries roughly
that the columns should be somewhat
uncorrelated each other and they work
for sparsity about Rutan again
independent and concurrent work of
Agarwal at all they give algorithms that
also work for over complete and coherent
dictionaries up to sparse the end of the
1/4 they do it through altering
minimization but one of the catches that
one of the steps is about solving a l1
minimization problem so it's more
complex step in the altering
minimization than what we're going to do
and also mention that there's work in
the summer
Squares hierarchy that can work for
nearly linear sparsity although the
running time and sampling complexity
turn out to be exponential in things
like the target accuracy so let me tell
you the main results so what we're gonna
show is that under suitable conditions
that there's a simple neroli plausible
update rule which I'll show you in a
minute which really does converge the
true dictionary at a geometric rate so
the error the column wise error goes
down geometrically with every step if
it's initialized to something that's you
know medium close one over poly log n
close and it uses a polynomial number of
samples in runtime and moreover there's
a very simple initialization procedure
which I probably won't have time to get
into which just uses SVD to get you to
this point where this theorem works but
maybe the main take-home what I want to
tell you about is what we really give is
we give a framework for analyzing
altering the ization here which i think
is interesting in its own right so I'll
get into that in a few minutes but you
know without further ado let me tell you
what the update rule is it's actually
even simpler than all Shannon field so
all you're gonna do is you're gonna
alternate between these two steps so
this is the decoding procedure is you
have your current estimate for the
dictionary which is a hat and what do
you do to find the sparse code you do
the simplest possible thing you take
your image your example and you just
multiply it by a hat transpose and
threshold it meaning that you zero out
the small entries and keep the others
and then what you do is you update a hat
according to this following rule so this
is the rule that I want to talk about
you know the way to look at this rule is
here this is the residual error so I
have my example B and then I look at how
much of it I've explained I take that
vector and then I take its outer product
with here's the trick I use the
component wise sine of my representation
that's the main idea so you know before
I prove things about this rule let me
take a minute or two to digest this rule
one of the really nice properties about
this rule is that the samples arrived
online
so as you're given more and more samples
you learn from them you update your
dictionary and then you move on so you
don't need to store all of the examples
to figure out how
you should update your estimator it's
all it does it stores the current
estimate and in contrast some of the
other provable algorithms they have this
annoying property that when you're given
more samples and you want a you know
better estimate for your dictionary you
might in principle have to throw out
your old estimate and start from scratch
but it's not true here where you just
use each sample learn what you want from
it and move on the other property is
that this computation is fairly local so
if you think about the entries in this
vector as being the entries in your
sparse code then each of those bits and
coordinates is just the simple threshold
that weighted sum of some neighbors so
it's something that you can compute
easily and neurons have the right
architecture to do these things and the
last point is I want to tell you what
this notion of hebbian is which I
vaguely you know alluded to before
they're actually one of the really nice
thing is that this update rule is
explicitly heavy so heavy in is this old
adage that neurons that fire together
wire together but the way to think about
it is if I ask how does my entry in a
hat update if I look in row I column J
and I ask how do I update what that
entry is based on my example then all it
is is since you're taking the outer
product of these two vectors what you
update to this it's really just based on
the product of the activations at two
different layers this is the sparse
coding layer that computes the
representation and this is the residual
layer so how you update is just the
product of the activations at the two
end points so it has a very intuitively
appealing flavor to it
now the sort of last point that I want
to get across is a framework for
thinking about altering minimization
which what I'm going to do is I'm going
to connect it to approximate gradient
descent so this will be the the
technique for analyzing such simple
neroli plausible rules and if we take
the old viewpoint the usual viewpoint of
these things is that here we have some
energy function we'd like to minimize
and the trouble is that it's a non
convex function so here the columns of B
are exactly our examples and the columns
of X hat are our
representations that we found so far in
our given dictionary but the trouble is
that this optimization problem is
non-convex because we don't know a
hatton we don't know X hat so this is
one of the challenges that if you think
about performing gradient descent on
some non convex function then there's
very little that you can actually say
about it because there are optimization
problems like this that really do have
tons of local optimum certainly in a
worst-case sense but here's the ideas
instead of thinking about it as a known
non convex function that we're trying to
optimize what about thinking about it is
trying to minimize an unknown convex
function so what I mean by that is what
if I take my energy function I still
have this unknown dictionary that I'd
like to update and instead of plugging
in you know instead of plugging in my
learned representation X hat what if I
plug in the true representation X so I
don't have access to this function
because I don't know the representations
of my examples that's what makes this
problem interesting but if you think
about it this function is strongly
convex and with high probability as I
take more and more examples it's true
answer will be the true dictionary will
it converge to it at a very good rate so
it's a function in which the global
optimum can actually be reached by
gradient descent so that's the idea is
to connect what altering minimization is
doing to progress on this function so
this changes what our goal is because
our new goal is to prove that the step
we updated the dictionary is really
somehow weakly correlated this
optimization problem and I'll make that
precise in a second the other point I
want to make out that I want to point
out is that there is this really
interesting recent paper of Balakrishna
and Wainwright in U which use a similar
idea of thinking about an unknown convex
function to analyze e/m given a suitable
initialization one of the things the
compare and contrast here is that their
framework is actually about the local
geometry of the function which the e/m
algorithm is attempting to maximize and
instead ours as you'll see is really
about the direction of movement there's
a lot of extra flexibility that that
will allow so here's the setting oops
here's the setting
which will be interested in is imagine
the following general setup so there's
some true solution that we'd like to
reach this is our true dictionary or
maybe a column in the true dictionary
and all that's gonna happen is we're
going to update our current estimate by
moving in some direction GS now here's
the crucial definition is that will say
that GS is alpha beta epsilon s
correlated with this optimal solution if
you take the direction you move in and
you take its inner product with the
ideal direction you'd like to move in
the thing which would take you right to
the right answer and you want that this
inner product should be non negligibly
large at least weakly correlated with
the true direction so it should pick up
a decent amount of its mass from here so
this is actually just so the point is
that you just need that the direction
you're moving in has some decent inner
product like one over poly n inner
product with the true direction you'd
like to be moving in so you just need a
very weak form of progress and it turns
out that under this condition it's very
easy to see that you do make geometric
progress up to this additive slack term
here and this is really the usual proof
this is just an abstraction of the
standard proof of gradient descent of
why it works under slightly more general
conditions but now I can tell you the
entire outline for the analysis and one
slide so the idea is we have these two
different update rules you know one of
them finds the sparse code the sparse
representation given our current
estimate and a very simple lemma is that
if a hat is 1 over poly log in closed
column wise the true dictionary and some
conditions on its spectral radius then
actually the coding recovers the correct
science with high probability not
necessarily the right values that would
be very difficult and require much
closer starting point but then the idea
is that if we take our update rule well
we've gotten the signs right under this
decoding step so our error is actually
much easier to analyze it's just the
simple linear term and the key lemma is
that under the properties of the
generative model and under the condition
that this decoding lemma works what you
can do is you can actually reformulate
how altering minimization makes progress
you can break it up
into some idealized step where it really
does make progress to the true column
and some error terms here which
contribute to it so that's the basic
idea is that this one step right here is
acting as if it's moving in the correct
direction but now we have this extra
error term which we call a systemic bias
which comes from the fact that we don't
have the true dictionary right now but
the you know final thing is that you
want that the conditions you started off
with hold at the end but this is the
general pattern for the analysis right
is that what you can do is under the
conditions of the stochastic model you
can show that altering minimization it
really does satisfy these types of
definitions you need to be able to make
progress towards the true answer so I'm
basically out of time so I'll tell you
about further results see one of the
things that I find really exciting about
this is that there's no specialty to the
particular ol chasm and field update
rule once you have this framework of
thinking about all turning them is a
ssin is making progress when it
satisfies this correlated with condition
well you can you can try different
alternating minimization rules you can
try and synthesize new update rules that
you can then analyze in exactly the same
way so there for example non neural a
plausible update rules which are just
slight changes for example when you do
this to coding instead what you do is
you project out the column in which
you're interested in right now and
project onto the orthogonal complement
and this slight change actually has the
effect in that decoding rule i've
actually entirely remind removing the
systemic bias so you can get all sorts
of things just as an immediate corollary
by plugging in different altering
minimization rules and I'll stop there
so the quick summary that I hope you got
out of this was that there online local
and hebbian algorithms for sparse coding
that can find globally optimal solutions
or things which are very close them
provably even though they're composed of
very simple parts like matrix vector
multiplication and Thresh holding that
those simple algorithms really can solve
non trivial problems and moreover we
introduced the new framework for
thinking about iterative algorithms
making progress by trying to minimize an
unknown contact
function just by showing that the
direction that they move in should be
somewhat correlated with the idealized
direction you'd like to move in so
that's it and I'll take any other
questions Thanks so that I mean that is
a little bit technical I mean it comes
from the fact that you know this is the
coding wanna will when you are whenever
poly log in close which is how you know
close you can get with the
initialization which I didn't tell you
about that all you'll be able to show is
that X hat agrees of the true
representation on the things which on
its signs so it figures out which things
are large which things are small which
things are positive which things are
negative and that allows us to sort of
charge the error in this you know in how
our update rule moves just to one of the
pieces in this decoding rule not the
other yes absolutely
so in fact exactly but so that's
actually a very good point is that this
type of optimization problem if you're
close enough to a true answer will be
convex but how close you need it to be
about one over poly n close and that's
the region in which you'd want to remove
the sign to be able to converge all the
way down but the sign is sort of
intimately related to this lemma and
analyzing what the source of you know
not moving in the idealized direction is
is it allows us to charge it more easily
but it's all about trying to understand
altering minimization when you're only
at a very weak starting point like one
of our poly log n plus yes
identification problems where you want
to learn the information as well as the
channel at the same time yes yep well
yeah so that's a great question too so
you can also connect this the things
like
blind source separation and independent
color analysis one of the catches there
though is something like ICA will work
with independent samples for the exes
but a lot of the algorithms do need you
to be quite close to being four wise
independent whereas what's nice is that
here you don't need completely
independent things you just need bounds
on their moments like you know the
probability that two different things
are in the support should be somewhat
close to what it would be if it were a
random sized thing but I think the
difference between those two is how
flexible they are to the assumptions of
independence here it's sort of a
modeling convenience to analyze some of
the source of the error but I can
elaborate more on that later too here
I'm assuming I am but I make geometric
progress in each step so the issue is
that the sample complexity and runtime
depend you know log logarithmically on
you know 1 over Delta where Delta is the
target accuracy now it becomes a much
trickier beast to analyze these types of
things when you don't have fresh samples
so even for things like matrix
completion it was a very different sort
of set of papers that show that you can
actually get exact completion without
you know having your your sample
complexity depend on your target
accuracy but I don't know the analog for
these types of results
I think practitioners would always want
to use the old set of samples regardless
I think actually the you know the thing
to tell practitioners is instead about
you know once you have the setup that
you can you're free to choose different
alternating minimization update
procedures so one of the cool things was
also just getting rid of the systemic
bias just by slight changes in the
update rule so I guess my main point is
that here you can sort of think about
very delicate changes in the update rule
actually having very different
rhythmic consequences and that's
something that I'd love to see better
but definitely when you talk about like
practical applications you would just
use the same set of samples the entire
time okay